Oh
could marc forster's song become the
football anthem of the summer a german
TV station has made the track its
official song for the european
championship in france but they're stiff
competition from Hobart luna maya the
veteran german singer and ovid footy fan
joined forces with DJ felix yen to
record a motivational song for the
germany site the footballers themselves
even popped into the studio
this is a recent visit to some bucks you
here in two very different worlds coming
together in a collaboration like that
from the Infinity selfish document but I
think it really thrives off that
character and dynamism genomic in devil
Zika but then West Germany team got in
front of the microphones to warm up for
the world cup on home turf in 1974
the tradition continued until nineteen
ninety-four when a now reunified germany
let their hair down with disco legends
the Village People the team were
ridiculed for the song which landed at
44 in the charts music journalist
Arsenio Surenos why so many official
football songs are a flop it when hundy
daughter [ __ ] plornish meals at some
point german footballer stop singing
themselves which was good you had agents
and marketing men coming in who had more
say in the matter some footballers
didn't do themselves any favors by
singing today that's led to the
professionals german singer oceania
landed a european hitch thanks to her
song for the 2012 euros the most
successful euros anthem though comes
from england three lions regular leary
conquers the airwaves during the big
tournaments
for the official tournament song
accompanying Euro 2016 the football
authorities chose DJ david guetta from
the host country France
so what makes a football song successful
living gone wrong there are three basic
ingredients that lend themselves to the
making of a successful amber then you're
in with good chance firstly and
crucially you need of course a chorus
for people to sing too
done and it's a good idea to throw in
some old match commentary and it's also
important not to try and include every
possible culture like for the World Cup
anthems to run with iron Sabine's of us
DVS the song needs to be identifiable as
coming from one particular European
countries or theaters and extra exposure
can't harm either Alphonse by andreas
behrani became Germany's anthem for the
2014 World Cup after a German TV station
made it its theme tune
there's some fierce competition for the
Euro 2016 anthem
both favorites and outsiders however
we'll have to wait and see who wins over
the fans in the stadiums and see what
the charts have to say and that all will
be revealed during the course of the
tournament